c'est une nouvelle tant attendue la
ville de chartres va bientôt ré ouvrir
les portes de son musée au public
fermé depuis le 1er janvier le palais
épiscopal qui abrite des pièces majeures
menacé par la vétusté et l'insalubrité
du bâtiment la ville de chartres ne
voulait pas reconduire le bail
emphytéotique
mais ce lundi au conseil municipal le
conseil départemental a finalement cédé
pour un euro symbolique le musée il est
vrai qu'un bail emphytéotique qui se
terminer en 2013 c'était difficile pour
une municipalité qui avait été hué à
peine un petit peu plus de dix ans plus
tôt de s'engager sur des travaux
importants
il était logique à un moment voilà de
pouvoir se mettre autour de la table
avec le conseil départemental et encore
une fois dans le cadre de l'intérêt
général
voilà les choses se sont très bien
passées et je pense que les chartrains
les aurélien sont heureux de pouvoir
assister à la réouverture au renouveau
de s'amuser
en contrepartie le conseil départemental
demandent le maintien du musée des
beaux-arts pendant au moins trente ans
ainsi que l'élaboration d'un programme
scientifique et culturel sur trois ans
l'association des amis du musée porte
déjà le projet d'un musée du futur tu
vas falloir adapter des scénographies
prendre des lignes directrices dans la
façon dont on va présenter les oeuvres
et avec notre conservateur séverine
berger qui a déjà bien travaillé sur ce
projet nous allons essayer de l'aider le
au maximum pour arriver à faire de ce
musée un très beau musée du 21e siècle
à partir du 1er juillet le musée
accueillera les visiteurs du jeudi au
dimanche
le reste de la semaine sera consacrée à
sa restauration